and uh yeah tell us about the the hotel
experience so that's what i want to know
okay no no
this this experience doesn't start from
the hotel it starts from the point where
we get off the plane it starts before
that it's not before we've left the
[ __ ] country it's already oh yeah
that's already
me and connor had two very different
experiences
uh leaving the country and getting back
in the country yeah so i mean how should
we do this how do we split this up
should we just go by section by section
okay so first of all the most annoying
part
which is uh
to get even on the plane you need a
negative covert test form now okay i am
making a video about my quarantine hotel
thing so that'll be in-depth stuff about
that if you're interested by the way but
i'll i want to talk more about it
because i didn't want to bog down that
video we're just complaining for nine
hours so we're gonna complain on trash
takes foreign
so this whole thing is like confusing
right so
normally if you want a negative test
most test providers would give you a
form say hey you're negative take this
and then everyone will accept it
normally problem is japan doesn't work
like that japan trend just decided we
gotta do things a little bit different
we're doing it our way yeah
how about it's literally our way or the
highway yeah right it's like how about
we just give you a form that you need to
fill out the very specific way that we
want it filled out and this just sends
fear down anyone who knows japan because
you know they're not playing games yeah
i have heard that
some some airlines will let you on with
the negative test and you don't need
that one but why would you risk it so i
was [ __ ] myself because i was like
how the [ __ ] do i fill out this form so
this form uh needs to be signed and
stamped by a doctor it can't be there
can't be a nurse okay has to be a doctor
the test can be administered by a nurse
but has to be signed and stamped by a
doctor right right
so but most testing facilities don't
have a doctor who's gonna stamp or sign
it for you so then now you have to find
a place that has a doctor that will
stamp it turns out like none of these
test centers have doctors that are
willing to sign or stamp things for you
right yeah so managed to find
i found after i basically
i went to the uk government website and
got the email of every single test
provider they recognized and sent out a
mess email to all of them this was a big
mistake because then what ended up
happening was it was one thread and it
was it was
replying to each other no no no no it
was a blind carbon copy so they weren't
really each other but for me it was one
thread yeah so i i sent this email off
and within about 10 minutes i realized
the mistake that i'd made because i had
15 replies in one thread and i couldn't
keep track you basically opened a forum
post yeah i basically opened a forum
post
directly to the person and so i got like
50 responses in the first day if you'll
be like this is okay but then some of
them were like yes this is totally fine
but they didn't re like say
yes to everything so so they i had to
then call up places that said yes and i
walked them through it i was like are
you sure this is okay and and one of
them was like yeah that's no problem
we've done it all the time that's
totally we've had people go to japan all
the time from our facility and i'm like
great okay so i booked on with them 150
pounds right it's like 200 right yeah
damn right so but
i know japan i i i know that i should i
should have a backup just in case
because i don't [ __ ] trust like that
this is i should because you have to get
it 72 hours before so if i [ __ ] this up
uh i'm i'm panicking to try and find
something so i booked two yeah i booked
another test but
i this this place said book a test with
us and then when you get your results
three hours later take those results and
book a doctor appointment and then get
the doctor to sign and stamp it all so i
did that too yeah so i had that first so
i went to this testing facility at 8am i
they shoved a thing up my nose i'm dying
and then i get my results at 11am yeah
and it's negative and i'm like great
great so then i go to the doctor and
perfect they they sign it all they stamp
it all it was all super easy but i had
to pay individually for both those
things so it's like 150 pounds for the
test again right or no 90 for that one
and then 90 for the doctor's appointment
jesus so this is already like 400 500
bucks just on the test yeah um i'm not
not not counting the amount you have to
pay for the test to get in the country
as well
you have to pay for like
like you have to like a lot of things
people don't consider is like i spent a
lot we both spent a lot on just tests
because because you've got to obviously
get tested before you fly out of japan
to the uk and then you have to get like
150 bucks which it wasn't 150 bucks and
then you have to pay for another test
when you land in the uk as well which is
also about 100 bucks yeah lots of tests
so many goddamn tests yeah like if
you're thinking traveling is just you
just have to consider the cost of the
airline that's not a thing anymore which
are also there they've increased the
prices on the flights that they know
people are flying so like a direct
flight from japan to london it was very
expensive compared to what it normally
would be um well you also looked very i
did also book valet but even then it was
still more expensive normally um
and so yeah so i got this paper and i
was like great i have this this japanese
document signed the way i think i sent a
message to rayna scully who'd also done
traveling abroad and i was like i sent
her a picture of the signed document i'm
like does this look okay
and she's like yeah it looks great and
i'm like okay good but i had the next
appointment the next day for the people
who are like yeah dude it's all okay and
i should get it i'll get it signed there
and all that
but to me it didn't make sense a little
bit because they i was like how are you
gonna sign all this stuff
when i have to wait three hours for the
results yeah right so i turn up to this
this test the next day because i'd
already paid for it so i was like
[ __ ] i mean i'll get another test why
not let me know um i
i go there and i'm like okay so you need
to fill up this form like no
what do you mean like no we don't fill
out that form i'm like would you i
called you up and you said that you
could fill out this form and they're
like no no no we don't do that we will
give you a full i'm like yeah but you
that's that's not that's not good enough
for japan i told you i told you this
yeah on the phone call and you said it
was no problem and they were like no
we're not doing that did you not read
the forum yeah
yeah
so then a woman a woman came out of the
office and she was like oh no no no no
come on you're going to you're going to
japan she's like oh yeah come with me
come here i got you guys yeah
and so i go there and i'm like all right
so can you fill this out no i'm not
going to fill it out and i'm like
why aren't you going to fill it out
she's like oh because the form i'm gonna
give you is gonna be enough anyway it's
gonna have your passport information on
it and i'm like
i'm like all right but i already knowing
that i had
the signed document put me at ease i
probably would have been very
uncomfortable if i was in that situation
yeah and didn't have a backup and i'm
glad i didn't because i got my test
results after you know filling out this
form and doing they they they were like
we promise it'll be fine we promise this
form will be enough right and so i'm
like okay fine all right fine so i get
my results back later it's got even less
information on it and no stamp no doctor
signature than like the other test
result i got to take to the doctor which
wasn't even the real one right so
they've given me this piece of [ __ ] form
and then i went to the website i should
have done this before like and the
reviews were like terrible for this
clinic and then i found out
it was a clinic but it was
like a
weird modern medicine-esque clinic
but but it was a legitimate covert
testing they they were allowed
right
not for official documents i'm guessing
yeah so then i was like all right
i'm gonna
i'm gonna see because now i have two
forms yeah when i when i go to the
airport i'm like i want to give them the
[ __ ] one first and see if they accept it
yeah and they probably thought i was
[ __ ] weird for doing this as well so
i give them the form and then they look
really confused they look really
uncomfortable and they brought like some
staff over and i knew they were about to
tell me like you can't get on the flight
with this yeah and i was like and before
they said anything to me i was like by
the way i have another form just in case
and they looked at me like what what you
mean like oh i have like another test
with the form filled out and they looked
at me like i'm like i was doing
something really bizarre i imagine it
would be they were like why didn't you
just give us it was like why did this
guy be like a bait and switch because if
i paid 150 bucks for this i wanted to
make sure that it was [ __ ] before
but
this man limit testing the system right
now
why did you like
i wanted to see if i had been ripped off
and i i realized now i played paper
please the other day and i feel like oh
this is what they did in paper please
some people just wouldn't give their
passport or something
but yeah um so um
he's testing for bugs
they didn't tell me they weren't gonna
accept it but i
they were like bringing managers over
and stuff after i had them this form and
i was like
let's not worry let's not kick me out
here's the real one here's the real yeah
yeah because like i i talked to like a
few people who had traveled to the home
country and back to japan before i even
flew and that's how i knew about this
quarantine hotel that we were going to
have to stay in yeah we'll get to that
but uh they every one of them told me
you need to get this form
this form that the japanese government
give you signed doesn't matter what any
clinic says doesn't matter what they
promise if you don't have this form
you're not gonna get you're not gonna
guaranteed to get back in right right
and so you have to look for a specific
clinic that can fill out this exact form
with a doctor
which is a lot harder to find than you
originally think it is right
yeah it's there's there's a big
difference between
getting a positive covert test which is
all you need to get out of japan but
getting back into japan you need to have
this exact form in order to get back in
japan
um and luckily connor kind of went a few
days before me so
i had like my own clinic booked and
hearing about his second experience i'm
just like yeah i'm just gonna go for the
proven way and uh yeah let's let connor
be my uh beta tester yeah yeah
it was just like it was so stressful i
was just trying to like just trying to
get a goddamn piece of paper signed yeah
and it was like impossible but you know
luckily i managed to do it i don't know
how it would be in the u.s um
i just know that getting doctor
appointments in the uk is quite
difficult unless you're spending money
like a lot of money um so and again it's
kind of come under a lot of criticism
rightfully so because traveling even
though it you know obviously it's a
luxury in general but like they've made
it ridiculously expensive to travel like
like yeah like we i've already spent
like 600 500 bucks on covert tests alone
yeah same thing which i you know i'm i'm
lucky enough to afford that but like
it's pretty [ __ ] that it's that much
yeah you know i mean like and it's yeah
it's it's weird it's it's annoying